SHOULD HAVE BEEN FOLLOWED AND IT
WAS DISREGARDED.
>> THOMAS J. HENRY, THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME.
>>> TURNING TO OUR POLITICS
LEAD.
QUOTE, PRESIDENTS ARE NOT KINGS,
AND PLAINTIFF IS NOT PRESIDENT.
THAT BLOW TO FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP FROM A FEDERAL JUDGE LAST
NIGHT HALTING TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
BLOCK WHITE HOUSE DOCUMENTS THAT
COULD SHED LIGHT ON HIS
ACTIVITIES LEADING UP TO AND THE
DAY OF THE DEADLY INSURRECTION.
IT'S A WIN FOR THE JANUARY 6th
HOUSE COMMITTEE.
THOUGH TRUMP IS GOING TO APPEAL
IT.
BUT AS TRUMP TEASES A POSSIBLE
2024 RUN FOR PRESIDENT, CNN'S
TOM FOREMAN REPORTS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND ITS DONORS
NEED TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO JUMP BACK TO THE
TRUMP TRAIN.
>> Reporter: IT'S A WHOPPING
AMOUNT, EVEN IN BIG-MONEY
POLITICS.
CLOSE TO A MILLION DOLLARS A
WEEK, ACCORDING TO "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
THAT IS HOW FAST DONATIONS ARE
POURING IN FOR THE MAN WHO LOST
THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
AND HAS YET TO DECLARE HE'S IN
THE NEXT ONE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS RAISING
MONEY THIS EARLY DOES IS IT
SHOWS HIS POWER TO THE PARTY.
I THINK YOU'VE SEEN THAT EFFECT
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE BEING AFRAID
TO TAKE HIM ON.
>> Reporter: TEAM TRUMP IS
RAKING IN DONATIONS THROUGH THE
SAVE AMERICA POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE, THE SAVE AMERICA
JOINT FUNDRAISING COMMITTEE, THE
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGAIN
SUPERPAC AND OTHERS.
COLLECTIVELY HIS POLITICAL
GROUPS REPORTED MORE THAN $100
MILLION ON HAND THIS PAST
SUMMER.
>> HILLARY CONCEDED.
I NEVER CONCEDED.
NEVER.
>> Reporter: POWERING IT ALL IS
A CAMPAIGN OF DIRECT
SOLICITATION EMAILS PROMISING
SIGNED BANLS, T-SHIRTS,
CHRISTMAS DECORATIONS LIKE THIS
STOCKING FOR $50, ALL FEEDING
OFF SUPPORTERS WHO HAVE EMBRACED
THE BIG LAW.
>> THE ELECTION WAS STOLE FROM
US.
>> TRUMP WON IN A LANDSLIDE.
>> Reporter: AND THERE ARE ADS,
ESPECIALLY ON FACEBOOK WHERE
TRUMP HIMSELF HAS BEEN BANNED
BUT HIS FUNDRAISERS HAVE NOT,
CALLING THE 2020 ELECTION
CORRUPT, TAINTED AND TRUMP THE
TRUE PRESIDENT.
SOME HAVE CONTINUED THE
CONTROVERSIAL PRACTICE OF
PRECHECKED BOXES WHICH CAN LEAD
SUPPORTERS INTO AUTOMATICALLY
INCREASING THEIR DONATIONS.
AS FAR AS SPENDING THE SIZABLE
WAR CHEST, TRUMP ORGANIZATION
HAS REPORTED GIVING LITTLE TO
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
EVEN AS THE PARTY HOPES TO
REGAIN CONGRESSIONAL MAJORITIES
IN NEXT YEAR'S MIDTERM ELECTION.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO 2024, THE
LIMITS ON DONORS, THE DEMAND FOR
REPORTING, THE RULES ABOUT
SPENDING GET MORE COMPLICATED
THE MOMENT HE DECLARES HIS
CANDIDACY.
SO HE'S STILL PLAYING COY.
>> MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
DASH, SLASH, CALMA, AGAIN.
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, I
DON'T KNOW.
>> LATE NOTICE FROM ONE OF THE
TRUMP SPOKESPEOPLE WHO SAYS HE
REMAINS COMMITTED TO HELPING THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY RETAKE CONGRESS
NEXT YEAR.
THEY SAY NOBODY ELSE IS BETTER
AT THAT THAN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THAT SAID, WHAT YOU DON'T HEAR
ANYMORE IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP
STARTED HIS CAMPAIGN WITH.
A PLEDGE THAT HE WAS SO WEALTHY,
HE'D PAY FOR EVERYTHING HIMSELF
AND NOT BE OUT SHILLING FOR R
MONEY LIKE OTHER POLITICIANS.
THAT SEEMS TO HAVE GONE BY THE
WAYSIDE.
>> ALONG WITH MANY OTHER THINGS.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS WITH MY AUGUST
PANEL.
DONALD TRUMP JUST TEASED A RUN
IN 2024.
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S GOING TO
RUN.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST ME FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
TALK TO PEOPLE CLOSE TO TRUMP.
IT'S CLOSE TO 100% CERTAINTY
THAT HE'S GOING TO RUN.
THAT'S GOING TO CHILL, I THINK,
ANY OTHER -- MANY OTHER
REPUBLICANS FROM GETTING IN THE
RACE.
AND IT'S GOING TO FURTHER
SOLIDIFY WHAT WAS ONCE A GREAT
POLITICAL PARTY IS NOW -- IT'S
BECOME A POLITICAL DEATH CULT OF
PERSONALITY AROUND DONALD TRUMP.
AND IT'S LAMENTABLE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, DANGEROUS FOR THE
COUNTRY BUT ALMOST ISSCERTAIN T
HAPPEN.
>> AS A REPUBLICAN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> PEOPLE AROUND HIM, CLOSE TO
TRUMP ARE INDICATING AND
SIGNALING THAT HE WILL RUN.
AND KEEPING THAT CONVERSATION
ALIVE AND KEEPING THE RUMORS
AROUND, THAT HELPS WITH THE
FUNDRAISING, IT HELPS WITH THEM
GROWING THE SUPPORTERS FOR TRUMP
AS IF HE NEEDS THAT HELP.
AND AS HE SAID, IT FREEZES OUT
THE FIELD.
THE CONCERN FROM A TRADITIONAL
REPUBLICAN OR A TRADITIONAL
REPUBLICAN STANDPOINT IS, UNDER
TRUMP AND HIS LEADERSHIP, WE
LOST THE HOUSE, THE SENATE AND
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND HIS GETTING
BACK ON BOARD IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC.
IF WE DIDN'T LEARN ANYTHING
ESHL
ELSE, WE LEARNED PEOPLE HAVE
GONE PAST THE TRUMP TRAIN.
THEY'RE GOING BACK TO THE
POLICIES THAT UNITE THIS PARTY
AND THIS COUNTRY AND NOT THE
PERSONALITIES THAT DIVIDE US.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO MOVING
FORWARD AS REPUBLICANS IS NOT
JUST LOOK AT WHO IS GOING TO REV
UP THE BASE AND BE THE STRONG
SUPPORTER AND CANDIDATE FOR THE
PRIMARY.
WE NEED SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO
WIN IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT'S THE WAY
TO DO IT WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU SAW CHRIS CHRISTIE OUT
THERE THOUGH, SAYING, I'M -- I
AM NOT GOING TO LET DONALD TRUMP
DETERMINE MY POTENTIAL
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDACY.
IF YOU DON'T THINK YOU CAN TAKE
ON DONALD TRUMP, YOU SHOULDN'T
RUN.
AND SO HE'S SAYING OTHERS, DON'T
LET HIM FREEZE THE FIELD.
HOWEVER, AS WE ALL KNOW, DONALD
TRUMP IS HUGELY POPULAR WITH THE
REPUBLICAN BASE AND THAT'S WHY A
LOT OF FOLKS ARE HANGING BACK.
>> EVEN IF HE DID DECIDE TO RUN
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE, BUT
IF HE SAYS THAT HE WILL BE
RUNNING, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FREEZING THE FIELD.
THERE ARE REALISTICALLY
REPUBLICANS LIKE NIKKI HALEY WHO
ARE UNLIKELY TO RUN IF HE GETS
INTO THE RACE.
THERE ARE CLASHES WITH RON
DeSANTIS.
IT WOULD BE UNCLEAR IF HE GOT
INTO THE RACE.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE ARE
FOLKS LIKE MIKE PENCE WHO WOULD
STILL PROBABLY GET IN THE RACE,
EVEN IF DONALD TRUMP WERE
RUNNING.
SO IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT HE WOULD
BE THE ONLY CANDIDATE, IF HE
WERE TO RUN IN 2024, BUT THERE
ARE REPUBLICANS WHO WOULD BACK
OFF.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHAT THIS DOES TO
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BEYOND THE
CANDIDATES THAT CHOOSE TO RUN OR
NOT.
WHAT DOES THIS DO IN TERMS OF --
THERE ARE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS.
LOOK.
TO BE CLEAR, VERY FEW
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN COURAGEOUS
WHEN IT CAME TO -- WHEN IT COMES
TO TAKING ON THE INDECENCY OF
DONALD TRUMP AND THE LIES OF
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CAN PUT THEM ON -- NAME THEM
ON ONE HAND.
BUT THAT SAID, A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS DO WANT TO MOVE ON.
AND WANT TO HAVE A GLENN
YOUNGKIN-TYPE REPUBLICANISM
WHICH IS TRUMP POLICIES, PER SE,
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES, TAX CUTS,
ET CETERA, BUT MUCH MORE
TRADITIONAL, AS YOU PUT IT,
WOULD YOU SAY RATIONAL?
>> RATIONAL.
>> SANE.
NOT, YOU KNOW, OPENLY BIGOTED.
WHAT DOES THIS DO TO THE GOP?
>> I THINK THE KEY THAT WE NEED
TO REMEMBER IS THERE'S THE NEW
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUP OUT
THERE, RIGHT?
IT'S PARENTS.
PARENTS ARE CONCERNED WITH THEIR
EDUCATION.
THEY ARE CONCERNED WITH SAFETY.
THEY CONCERNED WITH COVID.
AND UNTIL THERE'S A CANDIDATE
THAT COMES FORWARD WITH PARENTS
AT TOP OF MIND, POCKETBOOK
ISSUES AT TOP OF MIND, PUBLIC
SAFETY AND EDUCATION, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO RISE TO THE TOP.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE GOAL
MOVING FORWARD.
FOCUS ON THOSE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
>> BUT CAN I SAY, I WANT TO --
CONTROL ROOM, I'M GOING TO
QUESTION SIX HERE BECAUSE I WANT
YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN TO A
REPUBLICAN IN ARIZONA WHO IS
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR AND HAS
BEEN ENDORSED BY DONALD TRUMP
DISCUSSING THE VACCINE MANDATE
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS PUT FORWARD AND THROUGH
OSHA, THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH ADMINISTRATION.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF I WERE GOVERNOR RIGHT NOW
AND HE SENT HIS OSHA GOONS TO
THIS STATE TO VIOLATE OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS, I WOULD MEET THEM AT THE
AIRPORT WITH OUR DPS OR STATE
POLICE AND ARREST THEM.
>> I MEAN, THAT IS THIS NEW TIDE
OF TRULY TRUMP REPUBLICANS.
>> WELL, IT HARKENS BACK TO
NULLIFICATION, WHICH LED US INTO
THE CIVIL WAR.
SORRY TO BE SO DRAMATIC.
A STATE GOVERNOR CAN STOP
FEDERAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS FROM PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS IS PRETTY
CRAZY AND SHE SEEMS TO BE
HINTING AT FORCE.
SHE DIDN'T SAY I'LL SEND MY
BUREAUCRATS OR MY LAWYERS.
>> SHE SAID OUR STATE POLICE AND
ARREST THEM.
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S -- FIRST OF ALL, PLAIN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND PERHAPS THIS DISTINGUISHED
LADY DOESN'T WANT TO BE PART OF
THE FEDERAL UNION.
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA PROBABLY
DO.
>> SHE CALLED THEM GOONS.
>> OSHA GOONS, A PHRASE THAT'S
NEVER BEEN USED BEFORE.
>> THIS IS THE ANTI-GOVERNMENT
LANGUAGE OF DONALD TRUMP.
AND IT IS, YOU KNOW, SHE IS
IMITATING DONALD TRUMP.
AND THERE ARE CANDIDATES, ALL
OVER, WHO ARE DOING THE SAME
THING BECAUSE ANYTHING IS
ACCEPTABLE.
ANY LANGUAGE IS ACCEPTABLE.
AND IT'S THE BULLYING LANGUAGE.
IT'S COMING FROM A WOMAN.
THERE YOU GO.
>> WHAT DO YOU HEAR FROM
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL?
REPUBLICANS OUT IN THE STATES
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE PARTY IF
DONALD TRUMP CONTINUES TO WIELD
THE POWER HE DOES, IF DONALD
TRUMP CONTINUES TO ENDORSE
CANDIDATES LIKE THIS WOMAN WHO
IS OBVIOUSLY TROUBLED IN SOME
SORT.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE DOING THEIR
OWN THING.
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH SENATE
MAJORITY -- NOT MINORITY LEADER,
FORMER SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL.
AT THE SAME TIME KEVIN McCARTHY
HAS WELCOMED TRUMP'S SUPPORT
WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSE RACES BUT
THE NRCC IS ALSO DOING THEIR OWN
THING EVEN IN AREAS WHERE THE
PRESIDENT IS CHALLENGING SOME OF
THEIR MEMBERS.
AND SO, JAKE, I DID WANT TO ADD
THERE'S A DEBATE THAT'S GOING ON
IN DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW
ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND TO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WHETHER,
EVEN THIS WAS EVEN BEFORE
VIRGINIA, ABOUT WHETHER YOU
SHOULD FOCUS ON TRUMP AND
TRUMPISM AS A WAY FOR DEMOCRATS
TO SUCCEED IN THE 2022
ELECTIONS.
AND THERE IS A SCHOOL OF THOUGHT
THAT EVEN IF YOU DON'T FOCUS ON
TRUMP HIMSELF, THAT YOU SHOULD
FOCUS ON TRUMPISM BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
>> SPEAKING OF TRUMPISM, LOOK,
CONGRESSMAN PAUL GOSAR WAS OUT
THERE BEFORE DONALD TRUMP CAME
ON THE SCENE.
BUT HE THEN PUT OUT THAT TWEET
IN WHICH HE SHOWED A
PHOTOSHOPPED AN MAY CHARACTER OF
HIMSELF KILLING PHOTO SHOPPED AN
MAY CHARACTER OF ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
HE TOOK OUT THE TWEET LAST
NIGHT.
GOSAR SAID IT WAS TRULY A
SYMBOLIC PORTRAYAL OF A FIGHT
OVER IMMIGRATION POLICY.
>> WHERE IS THE -- KEVIN
McCARTHY?
WHERE IS HE ON THIS?
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
EVEN HIS OWN SISTER, GOSAR'S OWN
SISTER CALLED HIM A SOCIOPATH
YESTERDAY.
I MEAN, WHERE IS THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY SAYING
THAT THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE, THAT
WE CAN'T DO THIS.
THAT EXCUSE IS RIDICULOUS.
THIS WASN'T ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
F.
>> IF HE WANTS A DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ABOUT IMMIGRATION, HAVE
ONE ABOUT AFGHANISTA